eu fui para o Peru e fui para o Chile eu
tive um grande problema com isso porque
eu tinha terminado de assistir a
primeira temporada de narcos aí eu
fiquei meio amedrontado não tem o
pessoal chegava olha Senhora eu não não
t nada a ver com isso nunca usei droga
de craque da minha vida eu ficava aquela
apreensão porque no narcos é muita morte
muito tiro e eu vi as pessoas tudo
falando espanhol olha Senhora eu vi as
pessoas caminhando no meio da rua para
mimem qualquer momento alguém ia levar
um tiro mas por causa que as pessoas
falavam espanhol e eu tava com espanhol
na cabeça entendeu só que aí depois fui
achando tão bonito doida as pessoas
falando em espanhol que todo mundo
falava junto Ola senhora tudo bem olá
que litar ola s s a rua tem po ai mamãe
eu comecei a achar tão bonito aquilo ali
eu fui me lembrando dos tempos que eu
sentia Rebelde falei gente eu tô no
Rebelde eu olhava PR as pessoas rodava
gente eu tô no Rebelde eu tô no Rebelde
gente eu sou a Roberta